[Music]
and thank you for joining us for our
veterans voices special here on eight
news now i'm alex backett
i'm john langler throughout the next
half hour we'll be joined by sherry
swans give nate tannenbaum and fellow
correspondents
and we will share stories from the war
and how veterans survive life
after the battlefield now a lot of
veterans have a hard time transitioning
to civilian life that's where u.s vets
steps in
nate yeah u.s vets is a nationwide
nonprofit organization that has a local
office it's all about helping down on
their luck veterans get their voices
back
we met one such veteran daniel
farmer-keefe at the u.s vets career
center near downtown las vegas he talked
not only about
his job as a flagger at area
construction sites
my job is basically to control traffic
and to keep the
construction crews safe but also about
how u.s vets steps up
beyond job training and hiring maybe i'm
feeling down or depressed they have
psychologists here
if i'm having financial problems they
have financial coaches
you know to help you with your finances
if i need help with
clothes or anything this place
it really helps and i'm very grateful
for it u.s vets communications manager
kalanda scott couldn't be prouder of the
success stories among the more than 300
clients they're currently serving
just to see someone come in here and
like um
are looking down loss of hope and then
we can provide that for them
and just to see them like months later
like mr daniel like
when he first came in like he was a
completely different person but now
he has a job he's moving forward
speaking of looking forward kolonda
wants you to know about u.s vets
upcoming virtual fundraiser
noting the great support they've already
gotten we've had the raiders we've had
mgm just to name a few there's so many
but then that goes to show
you that it takes a community so this us
vets virtual fundraiser it's coming up
in just a couple of weeks a lot more
information about it on the us vets
website
and we have a link to that on our
website eightnewsnow.com
john all right nate they do great work
over there you know when service men and
women join the armed forces it's a
commitment to be educated in military
life
but what about the commitment when the
service is complete well one group at
unlv tries to help transition from the
battlefield to the classroom and to the
working
world it's called the fallen soldier
a memorial at unlv to honor members of
the armed forces who lost their lives
a reminder to military veterans on
campus the school recognizes the
other classroom they already graduated
from i was part of the push
in 2003 did the the entire
invasion bruno moya served in the marine
corps during the second
iraq war erin stepped over just a little
bit there how's the you looking
the memorial seemed like a natural place
to fulfill today's orders
let's all do a semi attention a veterans
day video
action these are board members from
unlv's veteran alumni group
moya is the incoming president a lot of
people don't understand the importance
of veterans
to unlv so we want to ensure that we
still have that message forward
the group works with unlv staff to help
veterans
help veterans if i was a machine gunner
how does that translate
to a resume how can we get that going
unlv is highly regarded for
accommodating service men and women in
and out of class
however there's so much more that they
could do
to assist our veterans to make this
transition
not only to the classroom but after
in getting a job and establishing
themselves in the community
local attorney john hunt served in the
air force and is a former veteran alumni
president
he also recently ran for clark county
district judge
they have a group of people that they
know are going through exactly the same
thing
we try to help the vets with studying we
try to help the vets so they can get
their benefits
everybody ready they fulfilled their
duty to their country
now these veterans can help others
fulfill their duty to their future
around 1800 veterans attend unlv
alex what a great story john thank you
well service members who survive combat
often face a number of challenges when
they return
but not all the scars are visible
michelle spent
seven years in the army but going back
to civilian life was not easy
she had trouble going out in public and
was eventually diagnosed
with post-traumatic stress disorder for
me basically
it is climbing mount everest every time
i leave my house simple task
for a person without ptsd i should say
is something that i cannot do for
example going to the grocery store
is a task i'm not able to do i'm not
able to go to target
walmart forget it well like many
veterans michelle tried a variety of
treatments and therapies but nothing
worked
then she learned about service dogs of
virginia
it takes about two years and 40 thousand
dollars to raise
train and place a service dog with a
person in need
after all that time michelle will
finally get to bring her service dog
home in a couple of weeks my hope for
having dottie is that
i am finally able to return to
a normal life again that i am able to
have a sense of normalcy back in my life
this is just
a tool for me to carry around with me
this is going to be
like having my best friend with me
wherever i go
the organization helps the veterans
raise money for the service dogs they
also help veterans find donations
grants and corporate sponsorships to
help offset the cost i'm sure they're
going to make a great team alex
absolutely dogs are incredible all right
still ahead here on veterans voices
honoring soldiers
who gave their all and all this tells us
we should not forget what these men did
and they're not even deserving of a flag
on veterans day
and it just breaks my heart how one
woman is making sure our soldiers of the
past are remembered
at the southern nevada veterans memorial
cemetery on this special holiday
that story is right after the break on 8
news now
welcome back to our veterans voices
special on 8 news now
american flags placed on veterans graves
is a rich tradition to honor the men and
women
who've served our country it's a
beautiful and
somber scene every memorial day weekend
in boulder city at the veterans memorial
cemetery
but the daughter of a korean war hero
buried there
says flags should be waiving on every
military holiday
including veterans day and she's not
giving up without a fight
i went out there on veterans day and to
my shock there was no flags flying
i expected to see a sea of red white and
blue
and i see nothing of red white and blue
dawn kramer came from michigan last
november to visit her dad
sergeant andrew martin kramer a
decorated u.s marine who died in 2005.
she had paid her respects in years past
but never on this national holiday
so i went on to my dad's grave with my
two flags and i put him there
and then i just sat there and just
looked around in disbelief and i got
my phone out and i started taking
pictures of an empty cemetery with no
flags on veterans day
dawn left confused and vowing to change
the scenery this year
people do tend to get these holidays
confused
fred wagger with the department of
veterans services says
no state is prouder of those who defend
our country's freedom than nevada he
says all veterans are honored
appropriately
with the help of volunteer organizations
veterans day
is to honor the living veterans
those who are still with us memorial day
is to honor our fallen heroes
the ones who are laid to rest in their
final resting place
right here in the cemetery andrew cramer
was lucky to come home from the korean
war
kramer was a young marine at the chosen
reservoir
in the brutal winter of 1950. thousands
died but kramer survived the bloody
battle with the chinese army
and became one of the famous chosen few
dawn says her dad
brought home medals of honor and
physical and emotional scars
that haunted him for the rest of his
days and all this tells us we should not
forget what these men did and they're
not even deserving of a flag on veterans
day
and it just breaks my heart but not her
spirit
dawn saved up to buy flags for her dad's
marker
and all of the fellow vets buried in his
corner of the cemetery it was actually
1384
in that section i respect her for
wanting to honor her father
and for wanting to honor the other
veterans who are interred here
absolutely
a local patriot guard will help dawn
place the flags
and play taps at sunset honoring her
father with his
own sea of red white and blue you know
even though my dad
you know had his issues i knew he still
loved me beyond anything else
and you know even though he was a
hard-ass marine
he was still human you know and being a
marine they don't like to show weakness
and he he was always proud to be a
marine
well dawn has a battalion of help
allegiant airlines is flying her out to
las vegas
and boulder station is putting her up
for several nights so she is getting
some volunteers she says she'll keep
coming back every veteran's day
until every grave in that cemetery has a
flag on it
ah she did it well coming up from
serving in the military to serving
other veterans we all have demons
you know being able to ride with your
brother or sister
you know you're having a bad day and
you're able to talk to them
you know they understand where you're
coming from still ahead the local group
finding peace on the road and why they
say it has changed their life that's
coming up next on veterans voices
[Music]
and welcome back thank you for staying
with us here on 8 news now for our
veterans voices special
after serving our country one local
group of veterans
is on a new mission the combat veterans
motorcycle association
is a group of vets supporting other vets
and they say riding together
has changed their lives we call it wind
therapy
it's just a freedom dustin cummins
proudly served in the army for eight
years
four tours in iraq and three in
afghanistan
it's how he became friends with ryan
good we actually served together
we went to a couple schools together in
the army and then
we ended up stationed together ryan
served in the army for 14 years
now they're both living in las vegas and
serving their fellow veterans with
another passion
bikes it's life-saving dustin
is the chapter commander of the combat
veterans motorcycle association of
nevada
it's a worldwide group with service
members from every branch
and it's about a lot more than just
writing we all have demons
you know and being able to ride with
your brother or sister
you know you're having a bad day and
you're able to talk to them and
you know they understand where you're
coming from vets
we tend to bottle things up and you
won't we don't like people to see that
there's an issue
the chapter rides all over from death
valley to zion national park
this is video from last year as they
rode through the las vegas veterans day
parade downtown
in 2015 the nevada chapter started a
program
called wheels for warriors they gift one
motorcycle to a veteran
every year
ryan was one of those recipients his
bike
and the paint job was all donated it was
awesome
wheels for warriors has since gone
nationwide but dustin says
it's hard to get veterans to apply it's
hard to give away a free bike
why well just a lot of people feel that
they don't
they're not deserving of it the nevada
chapter has quickly grown
it's a family and a safe space to find
support
if you need help we are here to help you
after years of friendship
ryan and dustin found themselves in the
same place again
this time their mission is serving other
vets
it's nice you know just get on the bike
you get your brothers and sisters with
you and you just ride
what a great story there alex thanks
it's it's so amazing that they started
that program here in nevada it's now
gone all across the country
and when he says it's hard to get
veterans to apply
you think oh my goodness how is that
possible but they just say i don't
deserve it and of course they do
and you know there's something about the
open road we profiled here on eight news
now coast to coast foundation
same similar group another group of
veterans that were riding their bikes
all across the country raising money to
help other veterans organizations
i think there's something about the open
road and being together that really
helps them bond and
and talk about their experiences and
enjoy things yeah and it's fun
all right coming up next year on this
program he saw combat during the vietnam
war
he returned home to improve the
treatment of other military recruits
i thought it was a it was the worst
example of leadership
you couldn't treat a soldier like that
and gain any respect from them
up next how he used his experience to
change how new recruits are trained
when coming up the ranks that story is
next in our veterans voices special
[Music]
welcome back to our veterans voices
special here on eight news now we are
honoring those who served
by sharing their stories and that
includes tony nadal he's an army veteran
who graduated from west point
led troops through some intense combat
in vietnam then returned to the united
states to push for change
lex gray shares his story
during the vietnam war tony de dahl's
personal creed kept him moving
moving toward the sound of guns
toward enemy soldiers they're throwing
hand grenades at me and toward
his own fallen company men we won't
leave anyone behind
born and raised by a west point graduate
that's all nadal ever wanted to do
there's a history of guys graduating
from the military academy
and doing the right thing for him doing
the right thing
meant using his qualifications in
vietnam i was very clear as to what my
duty was to come to commander
i was going to leave from the front his
ideals were put to the test during the
battle of ayadrang in 1965.
american troops were outnumbered by
thousands
in nadal's company 17 of his 95 soldiers
were killed
he remembers trying to retrieve a
lieutenant's body from a creek bed in
the middle of a fire fight i find
there's another soldier there who's
still alive
and hugo also got left behind and he
survives
uh i get taken back to our front lines
later nadal got orders to rescue a
platoon that was surrounded by enemy
forces
as nadal and his men moved forward three
standing on either side of him were
killed by machine gun fire
why the lord spurred me on that given
day
i don't know later in the war nadal was
moving through a rice patty
next to a soldier who was shot and
killed that soldier
had passed on another assignment because
he wanted to serve
under nadal because of that he died and
that that hurts
every time i talk about it that hurts it
hurts because nadal believes
above all in his duty to his own
soldiers you've got to be worthy of your
soldiers
i felt personally responsible
for them when nadal returned to the
united states he took what he learned in
combat
and sought to modernize the army in
training and special forces
he got a masters in social psychology
and eventually taught at west point
at that time he says freshmen were still
being abused as they went through the
initial plebe system
i thought it was abysmal it was the
worst example of leadership
you couldn't treat a soldier like that
and gain any respect from them
during his time with the psychology
department nadal shared a study of the
plebe system we wrote a study
that just devastated that system
the west point they see today and the
way they treat
the incoming freshmen or whatever
is derived
from that study that i changed in
nadal's army career you see
a sense of responsibility of taking care
of others
he told me he'd like to see more of that
in his own country
what we don't have in this country now
is a sense of i am
partially responsible for him
we are responsible for each other for
veterans voices
i'm lex gray coming up next here on
veterans voices a century of serving
a world war ii veteran who just turned
100 years old
shares his secret to longevity that's
after the break
on 8 news now
[Music]
welcome back a world war ii veteran from
virginia is reflecting on how he
survived the conflict
and life decades afterwards yeah retired
army major anthony granny was drafted
when he was 21
on the front lines of war in june of
1944 well that meant normandy france
just days after d-day more than 150
000 american canadian and british troops
landing along
50 miles of beaches but by the time his
group landed with supplies
the beaches were cleared at least
cleared of people
within the beach itself there it was a
complete chaos
burned equipment abandoned clothing
abandoned shoes abundant helmets
burned our jeeps so after the war grant
moved up the ranks served all over
europe
after 20 years of service he retired
that was 1963.
he celebrated his 100th birthday this
year
sharing his secret to longevity
have a positive mind have a positive
mind
things will get better tomorrow you
gotta like that grant and his wife
raising two boys two girls and his
family grew he's got nine grandkids
six greats and even one great
great grandchild thank you sir for your
service
absolutely you think about all of the
things that he saw when he was in combat
way back in world war
ii and uh since then it's such a uh
important uh
perspective to have as we honor veterans
here in southern nevada as well
and it's amazing to still hear their
stories and they're still able to share
them so
thank you for your service and they're
still giving back after all these years
that's what's remarkable i love that
absolutely well thank you very much
for joining us here for the past 30
minutes we've honored
veterans here in southern nevada
veterans all around the country for
their service here
on this veterans voices special you can
find more information about these
stories and other organizations at
eightnewsnow.com
thank you for your service
[Music]
you